- [Man] I think you
should never be scared.
(cheering)
(shouting and chanting)
Even if China stronger,
China will give you only good.
- You can talk here, not like China.
A dictatorship.
A fascist dictatorship.
- This is my book.
This is called in Chinese
(speaks in Chinese).
English, American Economy.
- We fail to appreciate history.
We fail to think,
and it's cost us fiercely, in that today
the United States is in deep decline.
- The problem with GM
is not caused by Toyota or Hyundai either.
The problem with General
Motors has been caused by what?
General Motors and the UAW.
- We're not very competitive.
We've been spending too
much money on making,
ultimately, worthless stuff.
- You are making weapons,
you are making tanks
to kill people, okay?
China is actually making
cups, utensils, cloths.
- We gave a lot of people
in a lot of labs and factories and things
good jobs to make plutonium
weapons, uranium weapons,
things of this sort,
for all of these years,
and it didn't contribute one iota
to either consumption or
investment in America.
It was technical waste.
And we're now paying the costs for it.
(speaks in Chinese)
Our economics has been
revealed for some time
as being ideological,
as ideological as Marxism/Leninism
ever ever thought it would be.
We take a book and say it's in here,
and this is the revealed
truth whether it works or not.
(speaks in Chinese)
- (laughs) Different.
China is a very promising country.
I'm sure, in 20 years,
we'll catch up with USA.
- The world hegemon has
historically always been
the world's most powerful economic nation.
The United States hasn't been
the most powerful economic
nation for a long time now.
And it doesn't look like
it's gonna come back.
- [Narrator] The decline
of the United States
as the world hegemon is
a necessary condition
in order for China to take over that role
But does hegemon necessarily mean empire?
- Hegemon simply refers
to an overarching power.
By empire, then, I think it's
a little bit like pornography,
you'll know it when you see it.
As China unleashes its tremendous talents,
as well as the power of
its size and productivity,
it certainly is assuming
a hegemonic position.
But, I don't think China
quite qualifies as an empire right now.
- [Narrator] But, historically,
when countries have become hegemons,
they eventually become empires.
Rome.
(shouting and clashing of swords)
Britain.
(woman sobs and child cries)
Germany.
(cheering)
Japan.
(guns fire)
Russia.
And, let's not forget, the United States.
(shouting and clanging of steel)
(explosions boom)
- The Americans don't realize,
we have probably a good thousand
overseas military bases.
- [Narrator] China doesn't yet have
this military capability.
But, what happens when it becomes
the world's number one economy?
Will hegemony lead it to
become the world's next empire?
Or, does it provide a much needed balance
to American militarism?
(shouting)
Should we be afraid?
- Seeing is believing.
So, come to China and have a look.
- [Narrator] Seeing is believing.
So, let's go.
But, not only to China.
Lets go to the countries
that surround China
and see how they're being treated.
Is China being a friendly neighbor?
Or, is it sowing the seeds
of empire.
China already uses its neighbors
to play big country politics.
Busan, South Korea.
One of the word's major shipping ports
and evidence of the
successful industrialization
of South Korea,
who's living standards now rival
those of the United States.
The US considers South Korea
a key ally in East Asia,
and it hopes that China
will help to resolve
the growing nuclear threat
posed by neighboring North Korea.
Like much US policy, it
misunderstands Chinese interests.
(folk music)
Korea used to be a tributary,
or satellite state,
of the historical Chinese empire.
At one point even referring
to itself as Sojunghwa,
or Little China.
It was split in two during the
1950-1953 Korean Civil War,
with the reclusive communist North
allying itself with Russia and China.
Meanwhile, the South chose
developmental capitalism,
and relied heavily on
the vast consumer markets
of the United States
to propel its rabid industrialization
through export driven growth.
Seoul, the nation's capital,
has a little more than a quarter
of the county's population
of 48 million.
It sits precariously at 50 kilometers
from the demilitarized zone
separating the two sides,
in range of the North's artillery.
Threat of Seoul's all out destruction
in the event of further conflict
has helped maintain this
status quo for five decades.
Just how serious a threat
is North Korea's development
of nuclear weapons?
(thunderous explosion)
- In order for a country
to become a full-fledged
nuclear weapons state,
the country should
satisfy four conditions.
The first condition is
production of nuclear warhead.
Yes, North Korea has
acquired nuclear warhead.
Second, they should have
delivery capability.
North Korea has delivery capability.
It has intermediate
range ballistic missile,
Northern One and Northern Two.
It has short range missiles
such as SCUD B and C.
Third, nuclear testing.
But, there's a debate on whether
it was successful or not.
And, finally, in order
to mount the warhead
on the short and medium range missiles,
North Korea should possess
miniaturization technology.
But, we believe North
Korea is short of acquiring
the miniaturization technology.
In view of that,
we can argue that North Korea
is a very dangerous country
with potential nuclear weapons capability,
but we cannot regard
North Korea as defacto,
a full-fledged nuclear weapons state.
- I don't find the Korean
situation unstable.
I've never felt that there
was a threat from North Korea.
I've never thought for a minute
there was a single North Korean
that was even slightly suicidal.
(chanting)
- [Narrator] Suicidal or not,
a nuclear North shifts the
balance of power in Asia.
Why doesn't China use its growing strength
to help US backed efforts
to disarm North Korea?
- One of the odd things
about the post war world
is the Chinese are absolutely delighted
to have Korea divided in two.
They used to try and maintain this
even back in the Tang Dynasty.
Korea was often structurally
divided into different kingdoms
with different support from the Chinese,
because it led to structural weakness,
inability to stand up
to Chinese domination.
Their policy is to prevent war
and prevent the unification of Korea.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Initially, when, let's say,
go back to January and February 2003,
what the Bush administration wanted was
press China in such a way that China would
impose sanctions on North Korea.
China didn't want it.
- If you're gonna work
on Korean nuclear issues,
you have to understand the Chinese context
and the fact that South
Korea is rich is fine,
but if Korea were unified and this rich,
it would be the size
of former West Germany.
That's getting to be a little
too big for Chinese comfort.
- [Narrator] If Korea is a
traditional tributary state
that China manages through division,
then how will it deal with Korea's bigger
and wealthier neighbor Japan,
who's rivalries with China
have spanned centuries?
The answer depends,
not only on the intentions
of the Chinese government,
but, also, on the attitudes
of the Chinese people.
Like Korea, Japan has traditionally
been a part of the Chinese cultural area.
But, it has also been fiercely rebellious.
After Japan became the first
Asian nation to industrialize,
it used its newfound strength
to create a modern empire
and subjugate its Asian neighbors.
Committing heinous war crimes
and killing approximately
30 million Chinese
throughout Asia,
understandably, there
exists a strong current
of anti-Japanese sentiment
among many Chinese today.
Although Japan was
defeated in World War Two,
it went on to become the
world's second largest economy.
China, however,
is now on the verge of
surpassing its old rival.
To many, both inside China and out,
the 2008 Beijing Olympics were
a symbol of China's rebirth
as Asia's preeminent power.
As part of the Beijing
Olympic torch relay,
the Chinese decided to bring
the torch to Nagano, Japan,
home of the 1998 Japanese Olympics,
perhaps as a message to the
world that the Middle Kingdom
was about to eclipse the
land of the rising sun.
Along with this message
came a tremendous display of nationalism
in the form of thousands of young Chinese.
Many received encouragement
and even financial support
for their travels to Nagano
from various Chinese
consulates throughout Japan.
(rock music)
(cheering and chanting)
The Chinese government requested
that the relay began at Zhenguo Ji Temple,
the same starting point as
that of Japan's 1998 Olympics.
- Actually, the Olympics games
is a very good opportunity for China.
Most of the students in China view it
as a great opportunity for
us to present ourselves.
- [Narrator] However,
days before the torch run,
the temple announced
concerns about the treatment
of fellow Buddhists in Tibet
at the hands of the Chinese
and refused to host the Chinese torch.
(shouting in Japanese)
The event attracted
a large number of loosely
associated protestors,
who took the torch relay
as an opportunity to voice
grievances against China.
- Generally, we don't like the protestors,
because they try to insert
political implications
to this non-political event.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think about the new railroad
that goes to Wason?
- Railroad is good.
However, most importantly, how to use.
So...
So, that should be used for Tibet people,
not for Chinese.
(shouting)
- [Interviewer] They are supporting you.
- Maybe?
(speaks in foreign language)
They don't know who is right.
(shouting)
- I understand that the protestors,
they need to get attention of the world.
But, I don't think
Olympics is a good timing,
because Olympic is a proud of
everyone of Chinese peoples,
so, if you protest it, you are
opposing the Chinese people.
(shouting and cheering)
- [Narrator] Beyond being a
window on Chinese nationalism,
the Nagano torch relay
provided a glimpse into the situation
of some of China's
various ethnic minorities,
and begged the question,
is China really the
unified multi-ethnic nation
that it portrays?
- In China's idea, from
ancient to until now,
we stress harmonious.
(laughs) Harmonious.
You know, Confucius.
Confucius.
Yeah, from his period 2,000 years ago,
he teach us be friendly.
No matter where you come
from, all corner of the world,
we are one family.
We are friends.
- [Narrator] The Olympics
provided an opportunity
to see if the harmonious
society was a reality
or simply propaganda.
We headed to Xinjiang,
meaning new territory,
to watch the Olympic
torch replay in Kashkar.
Inside Kashkar City,
preparations for the
torch relay were underway.
In a show of ethnic
solidarity for the Olympics,
the authorities were preparing
a large group of minority
children, mostly Uyghurs,
to come out and show support for the torch
on the day of the run.
The event itself, however, was
sealed off from the public.
(ethnic music)
(sings in foreign language)
We were struck by just how different
Xinjiang was from Eastern China,
and we wanted to know more.
Specifically, just who were the Uyghurs.
Well, to become with,
they're Central Asians of Turkic origin,
and they're Muslim.
Like other Muslim cultures,
the Uyghurs treat guests
with the utmost hospitality,
and we were invited by
a man off the street
to share tea with his family.
Like many of the minorities we met,
he asked that we obscure
his face and voice.
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Interviewer] Can we ask him
what he thinks about Iraq war?
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Afterwards, we
spoke to another Uyghur farmer
and his family.
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Interviewer] What was that?
What did he say?
- [Guide] He's saying about
the little situations,
about that cement factory,
Kashkar Cement Factory,
about a little bad for the farming.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, cement factories...
- [Narrator] We knew we
hadn't gotten the whole story,
but our guide wouldn't
give us any more details
on what had been said.
Although Uyghurs are, by far,
the largest ethnic group in Xinjiang,
there are a number of smaller ones.
We spoke to a Uyghur speaking
ethnic Tajik at his home.
(speaks in foreign language)
- He's happy about the
Communistic party of China.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
(speaks in foreign language)
In the past, they make a fire
in the oven in the house.
All of the inside of the house is smoke.
Very bad environment.
But now, not like that.
- Because he has a new house?
- Yes.
- So what is the relationship
to the Communist Party?
(speaks in foreign language)
- Oh, they are very, very
satisfied with the party.
He said never be able to
find another party like this.
- [Narrator] It wasn't
until we caught up with
exiled Uyghur spokeswoman Rebiya Kadeer
at the Uyghur American
Association in Washington, DC,
that we felt like we got
the other side of the story.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Do many Tajiks here go to Tajikistan?
- No, they don't.
They don't have the permission
to go to Tajikistan,
because Tajikistan is another country.
That this is the small country,
so, they have no permission to go abroad.
Some relatives of him in Tajikistan,
they'll be able to visit
him, but he doesn't.
(speaks in foreign language)
- A harmonious society
should be a society that
balance the interest of
different groups of people,
for example, the wealthy and the poor,
the majority and minority people,
the urban and rural residents,
and, also, it should be balanced between
people and the environment.
- [Narrator] We asked the
Uyghur American Assassination
to provide a re-translation
of the Kashkar Cement Factory clip.
- This old Uyghur farmer
is complaining about the cement factory
right across his farmland,
because the cement factory,
which is rebuilt, it's modernized,
and it's polluting the air,
the water especially, the farmland.
As farmers, they can no
longer grow anything.
He used to grow melons
and some other fruits
in the farmland here, but
now he cannot grow anything.
And he is really not happy about it,
and he can do absolutely nothing about it.
And he's complaining, basically,
if the Chinese were living
in this neighborhood,
then the city government
and the environmental protection agency
would have taken some measures
to prevent the pollution.
But, now, the factory
and the city government
are doing absolutely nothing,
because he says the local
government officials are corrupt
and were probably bought
by the cement factory.
So, they can do absolutely
nothing about it,
and it's really sad for them as farmers.
Yeah.
(speaks in foreign language)
(ethnic music)
- [Narrator] But couldn't the
Uyghurs reach out for help
from their close Muslim
neighbors, the Pakistanis?
(speaks in foreign language)
(tires screech)
(resounding crash)
Wait a minute, Pakistan
gets favors from China?
We were confused.
We thought Pakistan was
supposed to be a key US ally,
not China's.
It's also a predominantly Muslim country.
So, at the very least,
wouldn't its people sympathize
with the situation of
the Uyghurs in China?
Just what type of a relationship
does China have with Pakistan?
We decided a visit to
Pakistan was in order.
- There are two nations which
are fighting in the world.
One is America, one is China.
So, America is using
brutal way, which is war,
and there is a lot of losses,
and China is using a peaceful
way, and civilized way
where there is no loss.
- [Man] Pakistan!
(chanting)
Pakistan!
- [Crowd] Pakistan!
(shouts in foreign language)
- They don't interfere,
okay, in other country.
That is not like American.
That is not like America
who interfere in the entire world.
(ethnic music)
(sings in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The United States
is one of the largest donors
of foreign aid to Pakistan.
But, most of this money is
spent on American made arms
and weapon systems.
The Pakistani military
justifies such spending
as being necessary to defend
against the imagined threat
of its archenemy, India.
American aid, therefore,
does little to help actual Pakistanis.
Fortunately, for the Pakistanis,
there are other nations
that have undertaken development projects
that have contributed greatly
to the infrastructure and
quality of life in Pakistan.
- China has been our friend
for the last 50 years.
If Pakistan had any problem in the past,
China came and solved
the problem of Pakistan.
- [Narrator] The Karakoram Highway
is the highest international
roadway in the world.
It runs over 800 miles from
Kashkar, in Western China,
to Islamabad, Pakistan.
The KKH is a joint venture
between China and Pakistan
that provides a vital link
between the two countries.
A quiet graveyard just off the highway
commemorates the 82 Chinese workers
who lost their lives in
Pakistan during the 20 years
it took to complete the
construction of the KKH.
The Karakorum Highway
would not exist today
were it not for the funding, hard work,
and sacrifice of the Chinese.
- Before the construction of KKH,
the people of Kardinya
led very bored life.
After the construction of KKH,
we experienced different sort of changes.
Culturally, economically,
socially, and politically one.
- In in our area
there is no industry,
only jobs, little jobs,
and small homemade things.
The Chinese are only one of the country
who provide the which
is stuff for our people.
We are six hours our border to China,
so easily we are going to.
- China is so near to us,
so, you want to business with China.
- [Narrator] In addition to
inexpensive consumer goods,
Chinese technology is
also brought to Pakistan
through the Karakorum.
- The Chinese technology is very cheap,
so the local authorities
and Pakistani government
accept the abuse,
and they allow them to
establish their projects.
There is an agreement
between Chinese government
and Pakistani government
for widening the KKH.
(mumbles)
As well as gas pipeline.
So, the local population is very happy.
They will benefit it.
- [Narrator] The Chinese have also begun
other mega projects in Pakistan,
such as investing $200 million
in the construction of Gwadar Port
on the southern coast of the country.
- Gwadar is considered by the Chinese
as their avenue to a warm water port,
a port which is
strategically close to where
oil supplies go through,
a port which gives them
access to the Indian Ocean
and the Arabian Sea,
a port that they can
use as a trade corridor,
so there's the whole
idea of linking Gwadar
through Belutschistan,
onwards up through northern Pakistan,
through the Karakorum Highway,
going on through Xinjiang
and onwards into Central Asia.
- [Narrator] While most of these plans
have yet to become reality,
they reflect the ongoing
and serious interest of the Chinese
in maintaining close ties with Pakistan.
One region of Pakistan
that remains in great
need of developmental aid
is the northwest frontier province
in the federally
administrated tribal areas
bordering Afghanistan.
(speaks in foreign language)
This region is infamous
as a center of the Pakistani Taliban.
(speaks in foreign language)
The American backed effort
to expel the Soviets from
Afghanistan in the 1980s
provided weapons and training
to the Afghan Mujahedin.
But, the needs of the
impoverished Afghan refugees
who fled to neighboring Pakistan
went unnoticed in Washington.
(speaking in foreign language)
- They start their work at
five o'clock in the morning.
(speaks in foreign language)
They work for eight hours a day.
Do you go to school, does he?
He doesn't go to school.
(speaks in foreign language)
He say that they don't have money
to afford going to school, like,
their father is very poor.
All these guys look they
should go to school,
but they are working with their parents.
And now it's almost one
o'clock in the afternoon time,
and the temperature is over 40 degrees,
and they're working for their
family because they have to
buy food, or buy clothes, or
other requirements of life.
- [Narrator] Those who cannot afford
to attend public schools
find that their only
opportunity for an education
lies in the Islamic madrassas.
The madrassas provide a free education
and books, room, and
board to the students.
(sings in foreign language)
Students begin by memorizing the Koran.
Once they have done this,
they study other subjects,
like history, logic,
philosophy, and the hadiths,
or sayings and deeds of
the prophet Mohammed.
(speaks in foreign language)
- The government doesn't help us.
The government doesn't support us.
The government doesn't fund us.
If the government provide us fund,
then we will start engineering subjects,
or science medical
subjects, or other subjects,
or computer subjects.
But, I'm helpless,
so I have to take the
hand of someone, okay?
So that he can help me and fight for me.
And if you have one side
China and one side America,
we will be in the favor of China.
We will support China.
We will work for China.
(speaks in foreign language)
- There was a party among
the Pakistani generals,
when they were chasing glasses of wine,
and they said to each other,
they hoped very soon
they would send American
naked ass from Afghanistan.
- [Narrator] China's reputation
as a friendly neighbor
does not stop at Pakistan's border.
It has successfully been
out-competing the US
for the favor of Afghanistan itself.
After nearly 30 years of war,
abandoned artillery litter
the landscape of Afghanistan
like tombstones marking
the graveyard of empires.
- We have enough experience with the war.
We fought the Soviets.
At the end, that superpower was broken.
- [Narrator] Despite billions being spent
on so-called aid and development,
the country has become
increasingly dependent
on opium production,
with many blaming corruption,
and even NATO forces,
for the country's
inability to move forward.
- America wants to solve
everything by the gun.
Gun does not bring solution,
gun increases the problems.
- [Narrator] Like in Pakistan,
the Chinese have stepped in
to fill the developmental void
left by the Untied States.
- Right now, this reconstruction
period in Afghanistan,
Chinese, they are holding
some construction company.
They have built, they are busy
in some road construction.
- They are not even telling our government
who should be a minister,
who'd be a governor.
All they are saying that
they want to see a developed
and prosperous Afghanistan.
- [Narrator] However,
like its Western peers,
China's interest in Afghanistan
is not purely humanitarian.
Rich in mineral resources,
Afghanistan remains an undeveloped
source of raw materials
in a world in which they
are increasingly scarce.
It is Afghanistan's copper
that interest's China.
The metal is used in all
aspects of modern life,
including coinage, jewelry,
housing, transportation,
electronics, and medicine.
Afghanistan's untapped
Aynak copper deposit
in Logar Province is said to
be one of the world's largest,
valued at almost $90 billion.
(speaks in foreign language)
The China Metallurgical Group
has bought a 30 year lease
for three billion dollars,
the largest foreign investment
in Afghanistan's history.
The royalties alone will cover almost half
of the Afghan government's annual budget.
(speaks in foreign language)
(thunderous explosion)
(tense music)
(sirens wail)
On July seventh, 2008,
the Indian embassy in Kabul
fell victim to a suicide bomber.
Many, including the government
of the United States,
believed the attack was
carried out in concert
with the ISI, or Pakistani
Intelligence Service,
as an act of terror against India.
- When I came out from the shop,
I see a lot of people was
running outside the shop.
A person was injured in his head.
He was full of blood.
Lots of people was running
in front of the hospital,
so the ambulances came,
the police and security
surrounded the embassy and they
was not allowing any people.
(shouting in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Most of
the wounded were treated
at the nearby Jamhuriat Hospital,
built by China as a gift
to the Afghan people.
Fortunately for Pakistan,
the US decided to look the other way,
and American help was nowhere to be seen.
Will China show the same
level of tacit approval,
or will it chide its Pakistani friends
for sponsoring an unprovoked
attack against Afghanistan
and India?
India, home of 1.2 billion people.
In 20 years, it will have a
bigger population than China.
It's economy continues
to grow year after year,
and it's the world's largest democracy.
Could India provide a cultural
and strategic counterbalance to China?
- One of the main balancing forces
in the emerging world of
Asia, South and East Asia,
is going to be India and China,
that neither is going to feel comfortable
with one achieving a
position of superiority,
least of all any claims to hegemony.
- I would assume Asia is
a target for the Chinese.
They would like to put
Asia under its control,
in economic terms, in political terms,
in strategic and military terms.
This is where China has been active.
- India is very conscious
of China and rise of China,
and, also very much conscious
of the difficulties India
has had with Pakistan.
It is interesting to see
that China and Pakistan
have shared a very important relationship
over the last four decades,
and, in some ways, there
is a suspicion attached
in much of Indian mind
as to what is the modus operandi,
what are the motivations, compulsions of
such a strong and close relationship,
and often insinuation that
it is, perhaps, anti-India.
- [Narrator] And perhaps
that is the real reason
why China is so friendly to Pakistan.
Beijing's influence
also reaches into Delhi's
internal politics.
Dharamshala,
the home of the Tibetan
government in exile.
After the Chinese took
control of Tibet in 1959,
the Dhalai Lama and his government fled.
- In 1959, when China invaded Tibet,
we have very poor military.
If we had a very strong
military in Tibet at that time,
I think that Tibet wouldn't
have been occupied.
- [Narrator] Although the US and the UN
were actively trying to prevent
the spread of communism,
they did not help the Tibetans.
India did,
and an enraged China made
them pay a bloody price,
culminating in the 1962 Sino-Indian War.
- After the Dhalai Lama walked into India,
the overall China-Indian
relations deteriorated completely.
- [Narrator] The Chinese claim
that they are bringing
economic development
and modernization to Tibet
and its feudal society.
- China criticizes us, because China says
that Tibet was feudal
country, feudal society,
there was no, people were exploited.
And, of course, everyone,
you know, for us, you know,
we agree that Tibet was
not a perfect society.
- [Narrator] But, each year,
scores of Tibetans risk
disfiguring frostbite
to cross the Himalayas into India.
Today, refugees from Tibet,
continue to find new home's in Dharamsala.
So, why do so many of them come here?
- My name is Lisa Young,
I am from New Zealand,
and I've been volunteering
with Lha for almost two months.
Lha is sort of a community college
for adult Tibetan refugees
and Tibetans who have just
newly arrived in India
who are not eligible for
the school system here
because they are too old.
So, it's for refugees
from 18 to 40, mainly,
and they teach free English
and Tibetan classes,
French also, and computing classes,
and job vocational training.
And they hear about the education system
that's been set up for Tibetans in India,
which is separate from
the Indian school system,
and that's quite often impetus for them to
make the exile trek over
the Himalayas to India.
That, and the two main
reasons are better education
and seeing the Dhalai Lama.
Because the education in
Tibet is mainly in Mandarin,
and they don't get much of
a chance to speak Tibetan,
and they basically have to
learn the Chinese curriculum,
and a lot of them choose
not to, they don't want to,
they want to learn about
Tibet and its culture.
And it's definitely a
lot more preserved here,
especially in Dharamsala.
(ethnic music)
- [Narrator] Many Tibetans feel
that their ancient culture is
being systematically erased
by the Han Chinese.
- So these are the teachings of Buddha,
and it has 108 volumes,
and these are the commentaries
written by the Indian masters.
It has 225 volumes.
So, some texts, they carry it from Tibet.
It was damaged by the water, you know.
- [Interviewer] How many
of these types of texts
did the Chinese destroy, do you know?
- I can't say the exact number.
60% is destroyed by the Chinese.
So, they just destroyed.
They just burned and they
just threw into the water.
- [Narrator] India's ability
to operate independently
from Beijing is eroding.
- If you were to look around Asia,
China has replaced the US as
the largest trading partner
for almost every country in the region.
- [Narrator] India-China trade
has been growing rapidly,
and a trade route has even been opened
that directly connects India
and China through Tibet.
- Indeed, India-China trade
has crossed in the US trade
in terms of sheer numbers.
- There's a growing relation,
trade relation, bilateral relation,
between these two country.
- I think that gives Chinese certain power
which people look over
their shoulder twice
before they do or say something
that gets Beijing upset.
- Chinese have done,
committed a lot of atrocities,
and they've been allowed
to get away with it
because they've been isolated for so long.
There was a period in which
no one knows what went on in China,
and that they've opened up,
they're still sort of
acting with impunity.
And, because of the economic incentive,
countries aren't willing to speak up.
- Trade has literally
become very China driven.
- India is always very
careful about the Tibet issue,
and also with its relation with China.
- I think it's a tightrope
that New Delhi has to walk
between its increasingly
closer relations with Beijing,
and also keeping Tibetan
refugees population
satisfied as much as we can.
- [Narrator] In March of 2008,
there were protests across Tibet
before the Chinese hosted the Olympics.
(shouting)
Many Tibetans in India
decided to show their support
by marching towards Tibet.
(shouting)
- When we led this march, you know,
we walked for nearly four months.
(shouts in foreign language)
Even the Kannada government,
they have sent us orders saying that
you can't move out of this
district, Kannada district.
- India will not allow Indian territory
to be used by any Tibetan protestors
to undertake any political activities.
- [Narrator] At Beijing's request,
Delhi had its own police
enforce the wishes of
the Chinese government
by cracking down on the protestors.
- Yeah, you know, China's
already, China is very clever,
and it can use any country
for their own benefit
at any point of time.
(shouting)
- So, when we were reaching
the district border,
the Indian police stopped us.
So, from our side, because
we were trained what we did,
we sat down the road in the
middle of the, you know,
middle of the road,
and we started praying.
And some people were crying.
We all got locked ourselves,
we started praying.
And that made impossible
for them to get angry.
And they have their own responsibility,
they have their duty to perform.
They have to arrest us.
(shouting in foreign language)
- I think perhaps
I feel a bit of affinity
to the Tibetan people,
'cause my parents, at least my mother,
I don't know about my father,
went through the cultural revolution.
(shouts in foreign language)
It's just weighing on me a little bit,
because everyone things
I'm Tibetan when I'm here,
which is lovely,
'cause I've really grown
to love the Tibetan people,
but, before I came her,
I was warned by a lot
of local Indian people,
and also tourists that have been here,
when I told them that I was Chinese,
they were really surprised.
Some people were actually
saying quite extreme things,
that people might think
I was a spy from China,
and that people would
react negatively here.
They would get angry with me.
Not angry, then they
would be staring at me,
and they would make my stay
here very uncomfortable.
(shouts in foreign language)
I had to decide
whether I was gonna tell
people here that I was Chinese,
and, unfortunately I decided not to.
(shouts in foreign language)
And I think that was a mistake,
because I think they
would've accepted me fine.
They've got friends in
Tibet that are Chinese,
and they are very open and
welcoming of Chinese people
because that's what the
Dhalai Lama teaches them,
to show compassion to everyone,
your enemies and your friends.
- [Narrator] India's not the only country
where China tries to control Tibetans
outside of its national borders.
(ethnic music)
Nepal is home to 28 million people.
It is sandwiched between
two giants, India and China.
India has always had a
significant influence
on the culture of Nepal,
it's economics, and trade.
But China has become increasingly active
in the politics of Nepal,
with much Chinese attention placed
on the 20,000 Tibetan
refugees who reside there.
- The key word is predominant,
vis-a-vis China's relations with Nepal.
I think what the Tibetans are doing here,
what the Americans are
doing here vis-a-vis Tibet
is of utmost concern to the Chinese.
- [Narrator] Tibetan refugees
began coming to Nepal
after the Chinese occupation of Tibet.
The Jawalakhel camp in Kathmandu
is home to 1,000 refugees.
And about 500 are employed there,
manufacturing woven carpets.
The government of Nepal
is wary of being seen
as helping the Tibetan refugees too much.
- To counterbalance our overwhelming
political and economic
dependence on India,
we try to lean over backwards
to be nice to China.
It's pretty clear that
the Tibetan protests,
the Chinese don't like it.
They are extremely sensitive to this,
and that sensitivity is very easily
brought to bear on the Nepal government.
So, if the Chinese are
going to be angry about
Tibetan's running around in Nepal,
we are willing to give
that a sympathetic ear
and crack down on Tibetans here,
as long as China is happy.
- [Narrator] The Nepali
government's treatment
of Tibetan protestors is clearly different
than its treatment of Nepali protestors.
Police ignore burning effigies
and tires and blocking roads,
as long as it's done by Nepalis.
Although the treatment of
Tibetan refugees in Nepal
may seem similar on the surface
to their treatment in India,
the mechanism behind it is far different.
(guns fire)
For 10 years, a bloody
civil war raged across Nepal
as Maoist rebels took
up arms against the king
and the Maoists gained popular support.
After the king was forced
out of power in 2008,
the Maoists were elected
to run the new government.
The party's name is a clear
tribute to China's Chairman Mao.
(speaks in foreign language)
(guns fire)
During the civil war,
sherpas camping in the remote
snowy passes of the Himalaya
reported seeing caravans
of ponies loaded with guns
crossing from China into Nepal
during the dead of night.
- Our party's policy,
the international policy,
is equal distance relation.
Not more close to the India,
not more close to China.
- [Narrator] India has historically
been the major influence
on life in Nepal,
so, in practice, a
policy of equal distance
will require Nepal to
realign its interests
more closely to China's.
While the Maoists claim to have
brought democracy to Nepal,
in reality, their behavior is consistent
with that of their namesake.
(tense music)
Maoists stormed the
offices of the Nepali Times
and physically assaulted
Kunda Dixit and his staff
in an attempt to silence the press.
China was able to benefit
from the Maoist's willingness
to destroy the freedoms
of expression in Nepal.
In response to pressure from China,
Nepal agreed to ban all
anti-China activity on its soil.
China is bringing Nepal within its orbit,
but what happens now?
Once China controls a territory,
what's in store for its future?
Let's take a look at Hong Kong.
(orchestral music)
Hong Kong is one of the
world's most developed cities.
An icon of Asia.
The pearl of the East.
Hong Kong has also long been at the center
of imperial disputes.
It was taken by the British
Empire from the Qing Dynasty
after the First Opium War.
(speaks in Chinese)
After reunification,
the Chinese promised
to preserve Hong Kong's
highly successful laissez faire economy
and its political autonomy, rule of law,
and western style civil liberties
under a paradigm that would be dubbed
one country, two systems.
This is why Hong Kong is so crucial.
It is a litmus test
for Chinese intentions.
When China gains control
over an economy or political
system, what happens?
Can China be trusted to
respect that system's autonomy?
Or will China try to dominate it?
And, unlike other parts of China,
perhaps the best test
is not how ethnic minorities are treated,
but, rather, religious
minorities, like the Falun Gong.
- If you bump into one
Hong Kongese on the street,
or ask some kind of human
rights activities in Hong Kong,
what is the most sensitive task
of one country, two systems
is Falun Gong issue.
- [Narrator] The Falun Gong
is a modern Chinese spiritual practice
that was founded in China in 1992.
- This is a spiritual practice
that has deep roots in school
of Taoism or the Buddhism.
Our main principles are three words.
Truthfulness, compassion, tolerance.
And we believe that's the principle
that the entire universe operates under.
- [Narrator] It's explosive popularity
scared the Chinese communist party.
On the 20th of July, 1999, it was banned,
and the brutal campaign of persecution
began in the mainland.
Falun Gong practitioners
sought refuge all over the world,
including Taiwan, Japan,
the US, and even Hong Kong.
Compared to China, Hong Kong
remained an island of tolerance
for the Falun Gong.
Even today, as busloads of
tourists from the mainland
come to visit Hong Kong
and take in the view from Victoria Peak,
Folun Gong practitioners are free,
under Hong Kong's constitution,
to peacefully demonstrate
in support of their beliefs,
including displays about
human rights violations
by the Chinese government.
On the surface it would appear
that one country, two systems is working.
Or is it?
- One of the issues raised
when you introduce Hong Kong
is whether or not the Chinese idea
of one country, two systems is stable.
I don't think so.
- [Narrator] Under Beijing's pressure,
the Hong Kong government
routinely violated its own constitution
by refusing entry to
Falun Gong practitioners
who try to visit the territory.
- Every country have immigration control.
They are entitled to
refuse someone, no problem.
But, racial and religious discrimination
cannot be a reason of
refusing people's enter.
So, when we talk about
one country, two systems,
it's like, you know,
gradually really disappearing.
- [Narrator] Is one country, two systems
starting to become one
country, one system?
(speaks in Chinese)
- [Narrator] Theresa Chu herself
was deported when she attempted to visit.
- Chinese leader Wu Jing
Hao was visiting there.
We had 1,000 Taiwan
Falun Gong practitioner,
from six year old kid to
80-something aged old lady,
were violently repatriated
from Hong Kong to Taiwan.
They used some kind of blanket,
wrap me from here until
up around my knees.
In detain room, we have
no water, no refreshment,
no place to rest.
So, you can see, how hostile they are.
It's not like a free society.
It's not like a pearl of the East.
Why?
Because of black hand, the invisible hand
behind Hong Kong sovereign government
the Chinese reaching.
(speaks in Chinese)
(rock music)
- [Narrator] After being defeated
by the Chinese communists,
the KMT, or Chinese Nationalists,
led by Chiang Kai-shek
fled to the island of Taiwan
and designated Taipei
as the capital of the
Republic of China in 1949.
The KMT ruled the island
under an oppressive authoritarian regime,
but it was successful in
creating rapid economic growth
that has made Taiwan
one of the most industrialized
countries in the world.
Eventually, the KMT's iron grip
gave way to a democratic system in Taiwan,
creating the first true
ethnic Chinese democracy
in world history.
(rock music)
(sings in foreign language)
- Most important thing for each citizen
is to be independent.
I mean, yourself.
So, you have to independent
and the country be independent.
So, I think that's the
most important thing,
and I'm not that kind of
nationalist independent guy,
but I want an independent country
with all the independent citizens.
Think independently,
and do independently,
and vote independently.
Try to think everything independently,
don't believe in media.
So, I think the citizens should be smarter
and should try to control the politicians,
try to use the politicians as the tools
to achieve your ideals.
- [Narrator] An authoritarian regime
and rapid economic growth
leading to Chinese democracy.
Could Taiwan be a model for
the future of mainland China?
- If democracy exists,
and is established, more
strengthened in the region,
I believe it's not just,
it would not just benefit
the people in Taiwan,
but also benefit surrounding
countries, especially China.
- The youngsters on the mainland,
they are gradually changing
their worldview, you know,
they are not that inward looking anymore,
but they can see by themselves
what's going on in Taiwan,
especially in Taiwan's
democratic developments.
(speaks in Chinese)
In the long run,
we can change the very nature
of the Chinese communism.
And hoping that someday
that mainland China
can be converted into a
free and democratic society.
- We believe that China is
moving to a right direction
that develops the economy
and improve the quality
of life of everyone,
and, at the same time promote
democracy and equality.
- [Narrator] As the
Chinese economy has grown,
a process of normalization
between Taiwan and the mainland has begun.
(speaking in Chinese)
(cheering)
- I hope that the
mainland and Taiwan could
come together to work out a better system,
and, also, be more connected.
- [Narrator] Investment,
trade, and political exchange
have grown at a rapid pace.
- This a very critical moment for us
to develop a healthy and better relations
with Chinese mainland.
- [Narrator] But, is this
ultimately good for Taiwan?
Or, does economic integration with China
pose a threat to Taiwanese democracy?
(speaks in Chinese)
- They try to create this image
that, at least symbolically,
that they are a peaceful country,
they are rising peacefully,
and they wish to deliver this
sense of sincere to the world
that we are rising
economically and politically,
but, in a way that world
stability will be maintained.
- We need to accept that China
become really big power in the world,
but the problem is what
kind of China we want
in the future, in the 21st century.
Some people are talking
about that China may
replace the United States in the future.
But, if this China is also current China,
I don't think it's really a
very good thing for the world,
for the humanity.
- Being a big country,
being a big, strong country,
the United States of America should mount
pressure on the Chinese government.
- If the West really wanted
to speak up, it would,
but it chooses not to
because our products come from China,
we rely on China's economy.
- We never ask ourselves
what to we do, however,
if they get really so rich
that they're richer than we are.
And that we are making ourselves
utterly dependent on them.
- The world is relying on
China a lot at the moment,
and it's too afraid to
really speak up for Tibet
or for any of the other issues.
- I believe that the
international community
should continue to talk about
the human rights problems,
the democracy in China.
If not, I believe we are just helping
to create a new empire,
and I believe it's not good,
really for the 21st century.
(rock music)
(sings in foreign language)